[Music]  Bethenny Frankel's on-again off-again  boyfriend  Denis Shields was found dead Friday of a  suspected overdose a New York Police  Department spokesperson confirmed e.t  that they received a call just after  9:00 a.m. for a 51 year old unresponsive  male at shields trump tower apartment in  new york city he was pronounced dead on  the scene  Frankel and Shields began dating in 2016  3 years after the Skinnygirl founder  filed for divorce from ex husband Jason  Hoppy with whom she shares 8 year old  daughter Bryn much of their on-off  relationship was documented on the Real  Housewives of New York it's a really  hard thing to realize someone you love  is just doesn't mean that the right  person yeah and I wish she was  [Music]